here at PAX East there is a lot to do
there are these massive castles for
total war war hammer and there's this
giant incredible dinosaur t-rex for Ark
survival and there's all sorts of
cosplay on the show floor but the
coolest thing I saw wasn't even on the
show floor it was outside there were
over watch uber cars and they were
driven by stunt people dressed as
overwatch characters it was unbelievable
my driver was tracer fully decked out in
all the traits or gear but she was
actually a really rad stunt woman like
rev the engine as much as she could and
I just had a fantastic time and I'd have
to say it's the most memorable thing
that will happen at this packs by farm
so I spent a lot of time on the show
floor here at pax what I have to say my
favorite booth is the Adult Swim games
booth it's not flashy it's just all
games plain and simple and there were
two in particular that I think are my
favorite games of the show just katana
zero which really reminds me of hotline
Miami it's got this great 80s soundtrack
that's kind of perturb a duress and you
play as a samurai who can stop time but
you and your enemies are all just as
powerful and you get hit by one kill so
every time you enter a room you have to
kill everyone before they kill you and
if you get killed you have to start at
the beginning it sounds really
frustrating but it's one of those games
that requires muscle memory and you have
to think about what you did and learn
from your mistakes and I loved it second
one was desks gambit which is totally we
are gonna be playing when you finally
beat dark souls 3 and have nothing else
to play it's exactly like Dark Souls
only it's got this really great pixel
art style and is a couple of little
tweaks that make it feel I guess a
little bit more like blood-borne than
actual dark souls and the bosses are
awesome you have these tiny little
encounters in small arenas all you have
these giant crazy beats and i love that
variety so those are my two favorite
game of packs Adult Swim games good job
Adult Swim game
so the best thing I saw was a game
called Shadow Warrior 2 which yes is a
sequel to a very linear game called
shadow warrior the second one is not
linear at all it is procedurally
generated so you're going to have the
same objectives in every mission but the
place where you actually doing those
objective changes every time and it is a
shooter but it's not your military
tactical shooter like your call of
duties or your battlefields sometimes
you just want dumb fun and that's
exactly what Shadow Warrior 2 is I got
shotguns I got this crazy like cursed
poison gun I got Wolverine claws I got a
samurai sword I'm fighting demons it's
awesome sometimes I just want to turn my
brain off and kill and that's exactly
what that game lets me do so I saw a lot
of games at PAX but I'd have to say my
favorite one is out last 2 i'm a big fan
of horror games and i really liked the
first one so the fact that too is still
kind of playing on that sense of dread
that you feel throughout the entire
experience is really appealing to me so
has that look over the shoulder option
that kind of makes it's not just about
jump scares you know you're getting
chased you're just running into these
maniacal village dwellers whatever the
hell you call them so yeah it's about
this couple that are both investigative
journalists and they come to like see
what's going on with this darkness
that's fallen over Arizona are somewhere
in the desert in the southwest and of
course [ __ ] hits the fan and your just
rambling through this village trying to
avoid people would put your knives and
it's got a really gruesome ending to the
demo we played but I won't spoil it but
basically I'm really looking forward to
the game anyway we saw a lot of games
there's a lot of coverage on gamespot so
go check those out let us know which
ones are most appealing to you we'll see
you next time